KRISTEN FISHER IS "OUTFRONT."
>> THIS IS WHERE THE MAGIC
HAPPENS, WITHOUT THIS YOU DON'T
HAVE A HYPERSONIC WIND TUNNEL.
>> Reporter: CHRIS COMBS RUNS
THE HYPERSONICS LAB IN SAN
ANTONIO, HOME TO THE STATE OF
THE ART MACH SEVEN WIND TUNNEL,
A KEY TOOL IN HELPING THE U.S.
CATCH UP TO CHINA AND RUSSIA IN
DEVELOPING WEAPONS THAT TRAVEL
MORE THAN 5 TIMES THE SPEED OF
SOUND.
HYPERSONIC MISSILES AND AIRCRAFT
COULD BE THE FUTURE OF WARFARE
BECAUSE THEIR SPEEDS AND
MANEUVERABILITY MAKE THEM
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO DEFEND
AGAINST.
AND THERE'S ONLY A HANDFUL OF
GOVERNMENT-RUN INDUSTRIAL GRADE
HYPERSONIC WIND TUNNELS IN THE
U.S.
IN FACT, DURING A MEETING WITH A
DEFENSE SECRETARY IN FEBRUARY,
TWO PEOPLE IN THE ROOM TOLD CNN
THAT CEOs OF AMERICA'S LARGEST
DEFENSE CONTRACTORS DESCRIBE THE
SCARCITY OF WIND TUNNELS AS A
CHOKE POINT IN TESTING.
>> FOR THE BIG WIND TUNNEL
FACILITIES, IT CAN BE ONE, TWO
YEAR WAIT TIME RIGHT IN YOU TO
SCHEDULE THINGS OUT.
I WOULD SAY SIX MONTHS WOULD BE
PRETTY FAST.
>> Reporter: A CRITICAL DELAY AS
THE U.S. IS STILL IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF ITS HYPERSONICS
PROGRAM WITH THE AIR FORCE
SUCCESSFULLY TESTING LOCKHEED
MARTIN'S MISSILE CALLS ARROW
LAST WEEK AFTER THREE FAILURES.
BUT RUSSIA ISN'T JUST TESTING
THESE WEAPONS.
IT JUST BECAME THE FIRST COUNTRY
TO EVER ACTUALLY USE HYPERSONIC
WEAPONS IN WAR, USING THEM AT
LEAST 10 TIMES IN UKRAINE.
ACCORDING TO THE PENTAGON.
>> IT'S A CONSEQUENTIAL WEAPON.
>> AND CHINA SUCCESSFULLY TESTED
A HYPERSONIC WEAPON THAT ORBITED
THE GLOBE LAST YEAR.
>> THE CHINESE WERE BUILDING
WIND TUNNELS AS QUICKLY AS WE
WERE DECOMMISSIONING WIND
TUNNELS.
>> Reporter: ESTIMATES BEIJING
IS BUILDING A NEW HYPERSONIC
WIND TUNNEL EVERY SIX MONTHS.
>> WE REALLY NEED OUR TEST
INFRASTRUCTURE, OUR WIND
TUNNELS, IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE IN THIS FIELD AND
FRANKLY, WE'VE ALLOWED THAT
CAPABILITY TO ATROPHY OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
>> Reporter: THIS TUNNEL IN
TEXAS IS ONLY WAITING INCHES
WIDE AND TOOK ABOUT THREE YEARS
TO BUILD.
THE BIGGEST HYPERSONIC WIND
TUNNELS ARE 8 FEET WIDE AND
WOULD TAKE ABOUT FIVE TO TEN
YEARS TO BUILD, ACCORDING TO
COMBS.
>> YOU'RE NOT PUTTING A
FULL-SIZED AIRPLANE TEST VEHICLE
IN ANY OF THESE FACILITIES.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE WORLD
THAT'S TESTING IN A 20 FOOT
HYPERSONIC WIND TUNNEL, RIGHT?
THAT TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY JUST
DOESN'T EXIST.
IT'S SIMPLY TOO MUCH AIR.
>> Reporter: SO INSTEAD, THEY
TEST SMALL 3-D PRINTED MODELS.
THESE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
UNCLASSIFIED.
>> THESE ARE THE MODELS THAT YOU
CAN SHOW US.
HOW MANY MODELS DO YOU HAVE THAT
YOU CAN'T SHOW YOU SAY?
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF THING WE CAN
HAVE IN OUR WIND TUNNEL WHEN CNN
IS HERE.
>> Reporter: IN TERMS OF HOW
LONG IT WOULD TAKE TO CATCH UP,
THIS HYPERSONIC WIND TUNNEL TOOK
ABOUT THREE YEARS TO BUILD BUT
THE BIG ONES COULD TAKE ANYWHERE
FROM FIVE TO T